وافق المستشار الالماني على استقاله وزيره
الدفاع كريستيان
على ان يتم تعيينه خلفها الثلاثاء المقبل
وكانت لامبرخاذ قالت انها طلبت من
المستشار اولاف شولد اعفائها من منصبها
وذكر التقارير اعلاميه
مواجهه انتقادات شديده وتشكيكا في كفاءتها
اثرت تعليقات لها على منصه انستغرام بشان
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
دكتور
العلوم السياسيه بجامعه ستانفورد في برلين
اهلا بك سيد يعني
ما حقيقه هذه الاستقاله والاسباب الحقيقيه
وراء استقاله وزيره الدفاع الروسيه هل حقا
من نشر على منصه انستغرام اجتماعيه ان
هناك اسباب اخرى وراءه
اجي لكم
المستشار انه مع اشتياح روسيا لوكرانيا
فهي من الاولويات ان نقوم بتحديث القوات
العسكريه الالمانيه وهذا تتطلب حسن
التواصل من قبل السياسيين وهذا ما لم
تفعله كريستينا
الاعلام بانه يسعى الى ايجاد اسباب يلومها
عليها
وهي ليست ازمه ضخمه في المانيا ولكنها
تظهر انه بالنسبه الى هذا الملف البالغ
الاهميه نحن بحاجه الى سياسيه اكثر حين
واكثر براعه
لكن ان تتم او تاتي مثل هذه الاستقاله في
هذا الوقت الحرج ان الصحه التعبير
وفي وفي ما يتعلق بالحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا كيف يمكن ان تؤثر
على موقف الحكومه الالمانيه خاصه في هذه
الحل
نتمناه فعلا
لتصحيح الاخطاء
وهو امامه الان خيار بديل اللامبرت همم
شخص لم يشغل دفاعيا لا يعرف الكثير عن
شؤون الدفاعيه وهذا طرح الكثير من المشاكل
خلال عملها حاليا امامه فرصه لتصحيحه
الاخطاء ولكن اذا ارتكبها خطا اخر يكون في
مشكله كبيره ولكن حاليا
سوف يظهر مظهر القائد اذا ما نجح في
اختياريه شخص له ثقل ووزنه ويتوقع منه ان
يقوم بعمل افضل
المدى الجدل بشان ارسال اسلحه المانيه الى
اوكرانيا حاضر في هذه المساله وهذه القضيه
من الدول الاوروبيه
تعتبر وانا تعدديه كما تمارسها دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي كذابه
يعني تانسون
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي ولكن يبدو ان هذا
الاعتقاد او هذا المعتقد كان خاطئا
وبالتالي لابد من الاستثمار الكبير في
تحديثه قدرات ومعدات القوات المسلحه والان
من الصعب النظ- نجد هذه المعدات وتجهيزات
للدعامه اوكرانيا وفي الوقت نفسه ان نقوم
او تقوم القوه بما يجب ان تقوم بها الا
وهو الدفاع عن اراضي المانيا وكذلك
القيام بالمهام المطلوبه منها كجزء من حيث
شمع الاطلسي وبالتالي اعاده الهيكل مهما
صعبه ونحن بحاجه الى شخصا سياسيا مؤثر له
وزنه وثقل ولديه قدره كبير على التواصل
ولكن هي ليست مشكله بالنسبه الى موافقه
المانيا على تسليمنا الاسلحه انا اعتقد ان
هذا سوف يحصل وسندعم اوكرانيا ولكن
المساله مساله وقت بسيط لكن بالتالي
ان التوفيق بين مسالتين بين همم
التجاوب مع هذه الاولويات الالمانيه
الداخليه وبين الاجماع الاوروبي
للاستمرار في دعم اوكرانيا في هذه الحرب
[موسيقى]
تنا في حلف شمال الاطلسي وكذلك الدعم
اوكرانيا لان هناك توافق واسعم فدوه انا
ليست حربا تنحصر بين اوكرانيا وروسيا هي
حرب تعتبر حرب بالوكاله بين الغربي وروسيا
هذا لم يكن خيارا وبتالي يضع قائمه كبيره
من القضايا التي يجب مقاربتها على مكتبي
وزير او وزيره الدفاع وسيكون على الوزير
او على الوزيره ان يقوم به عمله اذا كان
لدينا المزيد من الوقت هذا امر يلائمنا
طبعا ولكن اذا جرى ايتها الصعيد هذا قد
يؤدي ربما لا استقاله اخرى ولا كان هذا من
شانه ان يقع الحكومه برمتها في مشكله اكبر
شكرا لك
استاذ العلوم السياسيه